>>Michael Mahemoff: Thanks for coming today.
My name is Mike, and this is Paul.
>>Paul Kinlan: Hi.
>>Michael Mahemoff: We're talking today about
mobile web development, how you can go from
a zero -- that's your very basic raw web app
-- all the way up to a hero on the various
mobile devices.
You can see up there we've got feedback links
and on the bottom of each slide we've got
the link to Moderator, too, if you want to
ask any questions.
So let's see. So HTML5 is here and it's mobile.
You've heard a lot about HTML5 today, of course,
in the keynote and some of the other talks.
I'm not going to spend ages convincing you
about the benefits and the power of HTML5.
What I will say, though, is that HTML5 is
also here on the various mobile form factors.
Many phones today, and tablets and so on,
they all support quite advanced HTML5 browsers
and run times, and we think that mobile is
an awesome platform to be looking at if you
want to reach many of these users.
Firstly, mobile is a very convenient form
factor for people. It's something that people
can actually use when they're standing in
a line, when they're sitting on the couch
or in the pool, as the case may be, and they've
always got it. And if you want your people
to be always using your app, that's a great
way is to have it somewhere where it's always
at the person's fingertips.
It's also a very personal sort of form factor.
People tend to have one particular device
that they've always got with them at all times
and they've got all their personal data and
all their friends and so on on it, so you
get that kind of relationship with the user
by being on the device.
Mobiles are also a very natural sort of form
factor these days. That wasn't always the
case, but now the kind of device that we're
carrying around with us happens to be a device
that's very much touch-based, and that's the
way that humans have always worked. We like
to manipulate things with our hands. Much
more natural than being hunched over with
this superficial kind of very recent -- in
the scale of things -- invention of a keyboard.
So actually being able to hook into that and
actually working our apps to be natural and
feel, that's sort of our tactile user interface,
is a big win.
And probably the most important thing for
you guys as developers is the fact that mobile
is an insanely popular platform at this time.
Many people here -- probably actually everyone
here actually has at least two mobile devices,
as of yesterday, because you almost all have
a mobile phone and you all now have a tablet
as well. And I'm guessing there are probably
people here with five, six, and twelve mobile
devices. So that's just individuals, but there's
also people across the whole world who don't
have any other computer device. The mobile
is the main way they actually get connected
with the rest of the world.
The flip side to all these great awesome benefits
of mobile is the development side of things
can be a little bit of work.
You've got all these different platforms.
We love Android, but it's not the only mobile
platform out there. There's still iOS, BlackBerry,
and many more in this, you know, huge long
tail of mobile platforms out there.
And especially so when you consider the various
form factors.
This is not just about the phone that you
carry with you anymore. This is about the
older phones that other people might be carrying
around, the traditional feature phones, and
many of them do have some basic browsing capability.
We want to be able to reach those users too.
And of course we want to scale up to those
very advanced mobile platforms that we have
now like tablets.
HTML5 then presents itself as a promising
opportunity, because the web runs on, as you
know, traditional form factors like desktops
and notebooks and laptops. We've been running
browsers on these things for many years. But
more recently, we've had the web running on
all these mobile form factors as well, from
phones and the much more advanced smartphones
and tablets to the more exotic sort of devices
like music players and eBook readers too.
Most of these kinds of devices, and certainly
any phone that you would actually get these
days, any tablet, you would be astonished
if it didn't have a browser, and in fact,
many of these browsers are based on engines
like Webkit, very sophisticated, advanced
capabilities, and some of the benefits of
performance and so on that we're actually
starting to see in the desktop as well.
So HTML5 is a platform. It does all these
things. It does amazing user interfaces like
you've seen today in the keynote. It does
-- the capabilities are actually behind of
scenes as well, the sort of networking and
offline capabilities that have only been available
to native apps until recently. We're starting
to get to a point where we're actually -- where
we've got these comparable features in the
HTML5 stack.
So it is an awesome opportunity to actually
take advantage of HTML5 to reach all of those
mobile users and get all those benefits, but
we have to think about these two aspects,
which is firstly user experience. We want
to hold our heads up high, as HTML developers.
We want to actually be able to say, you know,
"Yeah, this is actually a really compelling,
rich, multimedia experience, just like you're
used to on modern mobile devices," and at
the same time, we're developers, right? We're
all developers here. We really care about
making our life easier too. We don't want
to have to end up writing a million and one
different apps for all of these different
form factors. We want to think about ways
to optimize between these two forces of user
experience and developer experience.
>>Paul Kinlan: So we've identified these kind
of six fundamental challenges that you as
developers today face building these rich,
awesome user experiences for the mobile web.
The first and probably one of the most important
is, you know, different interaction styles.
How do you build applications and can you
build applications that work across all the
different types of form factors that we mentioned
earlier? Can you build an application that
works across the Opera Mini style devices
or tablets, smartphones, you know, the whole
range? Is it possible just to build one application
that is deployed across all these different
types of devices?
Users expect their applications to load in
like pretty much instantly and respond quickly
to their, you know, gestures and commands.
Is it possible to build applications that
-- you know, with the types of speed and interactivity
that we get from the native platforms on the
mobile web?
And we're all used to this. We've used our
web browser and we've been on a train or kind
of a semipermanent Internet connection. We
just can't use our web browser. But is it
actually possible to build applications that
work entirely when you're offline or in the
cases where you've got this kind of intermittent
Internet connection?
Each of these devices has a marketplace or
a store built directly into them, so, you
know, how can we get our applications discovered
when we're building mobile Web applications?
Is it possible?
If you look at the -- kind of the trend of
browser development, you'll notice that the
primary input mechanisms has always been keys
and mouse, but with all these new types of
devices primarily being touch-based, can we
build applications that aren't just responsive
to kind of the single presses but the rich
gestures that we expect from native applications.
So is that possible on the mobile web today?
And we kind of have to forget about the different
form factors. Is it possible to build applications
that are responsive to the variety of different
screen sizes that we see? In just one class
of device -- say smartphones or even tablets
-- they've all got different -- fundamentally
different size screens and resolutions. Can
we build applications that, you know, look
great on all these types of devices?
So I have a question for you all. Raise your
hand if you think we can solve every single
one of these challenges today on the mobile
web.
I've got a couple of people.
>>Michael Mahemoff: A lot of confidence here.
>>Paul Kinlan: So we can accept that. We can
expand that a little bit easier. Can we solve
any of these challenges today on the mobile
web?
A couple more people.
Well, no, we can't.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Sorry.
[Laughter]
>>Paul Kinlan: So we have 45 minutes for questions.
Has anyone got any?
[Laughter]
>>Paul Kinlan: You know, of course we can
solve these problems, and we're here today
to try and educate you in ways that, you know,
we think we can build these applications to
take advantage of all the latest modern advancements
in web browse technology, but also kind of
give that, you know, user experience that
users expect from applications, regardless
of whether they're native or whether they're
actually on the web platform.
So I would like to introduce an application
we've written today called IO Reader. It's
a special demo application just for today.
The code will be live at the end of this presentation.
And essentially it's a news reading application.
It embodies all of the -- kind of the problems
that we face on the mobile web today. We want
our applications to work offline but most
Web applications don't, and we think we've
built our application to solve all these challenges.
It's built using all the modern web technologies
that we as, you know, kind of progressive
web developers use today, so things like node
and Modernizer and everything. And without
much further ado, we're going to jump into
a demo.
So we've built this application. It's on the
mobile -- the smartphone form factor, and
if you've seen -- oh, here we go. Move it
up.
If you've ever seen the news and weather native
application, you'll notice it looks quite
familiar.
We have the traditional kind of scroll inside
the application. And then we can also embed
your click-on and read an article. We have
the nice gesture support so we can fling articles.
The really cool thing about this is we're
actually using consistent URLs throughout
this whole application structure, so we can
take advantage of some native capabilities
such as share. So we can share individual
pieces of functionality or pages from our
Web app, the kind of things that everyone
expects from Web apps. We just built this
application to take advantage of that.
We have nice usage of the browser-based back
button, and as you'll see, we didn't actually
reload the page. The whole user experience
was contained inside our application. It just
kind of works really nicely.
We've got the ability, also, to take advantage
of gestures like the gestures that we see
on these native platforms like swipes.
And then we've also got some nice little piece
of -- hopefully this will work -- yeah. So
we've got a refresh functionality. The kind
of things that we're starting to see in the
-- say the mobile native platforms for, say,
refreshing and reloading data, we've built
that into this application, too.
It also supports device orientation changes,
so again, we can still swipe between the articles.
It's just a really nice example of an application
which we've built just using plain HTML JavaScript
that works across smartphones.
But as we said before, the mobile web isn't
just about smartphones and building applications
that work on phones. It's also about tablets.
So the same application with the exact same
HTML, 90% of the same JavaScript, is targeted
to the tablet form factor, and as you can
see, it's -- well, the functionality is equivalent
to the application that we had. We had the
categories and articles. We had the dynamic
loading of data into the articles, so it's
quick and responsive to your commands. But
it's definitely optimized for the tablet experience
so we can go through these articles. The really
cool thing is, we had an engineer from the
Mountain View office build this application.
Mike actually built the smartphones application
as well. And we didn't have to talk to each
other too much.
But, yeah, we have this tablet application.
It looks absolutely beautiful.
>>Michael Mahemoff: So I'm going to shift
back here.
So we actually just went through those six
challenges that we've identified as the main
challenges we think HTML5 developers need
to solve if they want to actually make their
apps work nicely on the mobile, and we've
shown you these apps here, smartphone and
tablet. So we want to take you through now,
how have we solved each of these six challenges.
And the first of those challenges is dealing
with different interaction styles.
We want to actually make sure that we're actually
looking at different form factors, like the
phone versus the tablet, as not just about
the fact that we've got extra screen width
or extra resolution, but actually about the
sorts of interactions people have come to
expect. I think you've already seen that with
the phone, that it's the sort of thing you
can just get quick information, click and
do something. The tablet sort of interface
is more about exploring and you get pictures
and it's that sort of more browsing experience,
a bit more of a relaxed experience.
And our intuition is, we want to go across
the board with each of our form factors writing
separate UIs and separate actually mini applications
based on the common core.
We start with the principle that we just have
HTML. This is really how the web is supposed
to work. It's supposed to work as structured,
semantic content, and with HTML5 we get extra
structure. We can actually have these tags
like header and section, which are -- give
a bit more meaning to what's actually on the
page. And this, in itself, is a great thing.
This is actually what is sitting on the Internet
for this app. And when you've got that content
sitting on the Internet, people can make use
of it. You've already got a kind of API without
having to go and deliberately create one,
and it's something that people can make use
of and it's great for SEO and for accessibility.
And it's also great for people who have these
older kind of browsers as well. Anyone here
use Lynx? Okay. A few fans.
So this is the real version of Lynx here,
so we've got our app sitting in Lynx and let
me see. I can open up an article and it's
quite readable from just a very basic browser.
So our idea is that we can go all the way
up from the zero browser to the hero browser.
Likewise, we can actually do this with mobile
as well, so we've got another demo here on
Opera Mini.
And Opera Mini, if you don't know, is a very
basic sort of browser that does a lot of image
compression and strips a lot of JavaScript
to make it a very minimal experience for people
who don't have high bandwidth.
So our app works nicely on that too.
Sorry. It's not very well lit up there, but
hopefully you can see that.
And same thing. You can then open up individual
articles.
So all based on that principle that you have
just some bit of common markup and the whole
thing works nicely without any JavaScript
at all.
But that's not -- the benefit of that is not
just about the fact that there are people
using these browsers like Lynx and Opera Mini,
it is also about just the fact that that's
how we've architected our applications. We
actually start with that common base and then
each of those layers can actually build on
top of that. So, you know, that's our idea.
Here we use this principle of progressive
enhancement from the basic app. So we go from
that very basic app, add these extra layers,
to actually make it a compelling experience
and one that's relevant to each of the form
factors.
We use the principle of feature detection
to actually see if a single feature is there.
If we can use it, then we will actually go
ahead and use it on this browser.
That's kind of the point about when we say
that HTML5 runs so-called everywhere, it is
not a magic bullet much. It is not like saying
you just create your app once and it will
magically work everywhere. That can sometimes
be the case. It is more about recognizing
that you have got this common stack of technologies
running on all of these different devices.
And if you can put a little bit of intelligence
in your app about dealing with these different
types of devices, then you get the benefit
of all the re-use of that common code base
and the fact that you only have to learn about
one set of widgets and one language.
But we're going beyond the idea of feature
detection in this talk, and we are introducing
a concept that we're calling form factor detection.
And our intuition being, that you can't just
algorithm away the distinction between a mobile
and a desktop and a TV. You want just say,
Oh, we are dealing with a TV now, so we will
just add an extra 27 columns to our reader
app.
It is more about understanding what are the
users trying to do with a TV. It is a lean-back,
more of a lazy, perhaps a social experience.
With a phone, it is, I want the information
now. With a desktop, it is something you might
spend hours and hours working on. So you have
to have qualitatively different sorts of interfaces
for this but you don't want to have a million
different interfaces for every model and every
device.
We are trying to go for this happy medium
here with the idea of a form factor and actually
acknowledging that that's really the thing
that we want to be targeting.
So we created this library called formfactorjs
which, basically, does the best job it can
to detect what's the current form factor this
app is running in.
If it is a phone, then it will run -- it will
load these libraries and JavaScript and CSS.
And if it is a desktop, it will load these
other ones so you can build these small layers.
That's what we're aiming for, is a big core
of common logic. You have already seen it
with the phone and the tablet. They are using
the same markup. They have the same content
for doing things -- or the same code for doing
things like retrieving the actual articles
that you have seen on the reader, retrieving
the categories, caching them, actually being
aware of what the user is doing. All of that
is actually common code, and we create these
small layers -- we love to call them awesome
layers -- for just very specific code that's
relevant to the user interface.
So this is the kind of thing you'll see if
you actually look at one of those awesome
layers. It is the phone, JavaScript and it
is able to respond to semantic events. That's
the contract that you have to conform to in
our architecture if you want to actually respond
to events like when the users just change
the category, when the users change the article.
You can't actually jump in. You can't actually
provide some custom JavaScript. But a lot
of that is taken care by the common code on
both the client and the server.
On the HTML and CSS side, we also have a patent
we use where we actually identify that there
are particular states in our apps. As well
as having distinct form factors, within each
-- within our app, we have distinct states.
We go from a menu state where you're seeing
all of the categories and maybe a welcome
screen to a category state where you are looking
at a single category like music and technology.
And then we go to an individual article when
you are actually reading the article.
Whether you are looking at the phone or the
tablet or even the very basic interfaces,
you've always got those three states. Again,
the contract is if you are writing a layer,
you're going to fill in the CSS for how the
app should look in that state. And by putting
that class on the route element, you can actually
define the entire CSS for your app, the entire
style of each component in the CSS for that
particular user interface for that particular
form factor.
And we see that here. This is the kind of
CSS you'll see for the phone, where it's doing
things like if we're in the article state,
then we'll show the active article with overflow
visible. So we actually show the extra content
and so on and so forth. We create all that
style for each of those states. That's what
you can do.
If you have already written the phone layer
and you are going on to create the tablet
layer, it is very straightforward. You know
exactly what you have to do. You just basically
fill in what do I need to do when I'm responding
to those events on the JavaScript slide and
what's the CSS like on the HTML and CSS side.
We actually use a framework called LESS instead
of raw CSS. LESS is one of several frameworks
going around right now that's a kind of CSS++.
It is not a complete new language. It adds
a little bit of syntactic sugar that we found
very convenient for this sort of architecture.
You can see here, you can do what you can't
do in normal CSS, which is you can actually
have a hierarchy, pretty intuitive. It is
just the same as having article state before
all of those things.
Another benefit of these high-level CSS frameworks
is we have the idea of macros. So no more
repeating the same color code 27 times in
your style sheet. We can actually have a single
color palette style sheet. We can then reuse
that across all of the different form factors.
If we want to tweak our branding, we can just
do that all in one place.
>>Paul Kinlan: How do we build applications
that are quick, nearly instant to load and
then respond rapidly to the user's gestures
and commands? Well, we built our application
as a single-page app.
The theory being behind this is we don't want
to have the user transition between Article
A, Article B and then have a five-second delay
with a white screen of the application doing
nothing. It kind of really breaks that whole
user experience and isn't something that you
see in native applications.
Single-page apps aren't actually a new concept.
If you have been doing a lot of kind of AJAX
development recently in the past ten years,
eight years, you will be used to this type
of thing. It is really good on mobile-style
devices because you don't exactly know what
type of network you are dealing with it. It
would be a low-latency network, WiFi connection,
or a high-latency network.
Single-page applications, they keep all the
logic and functionality inside that one page,
but incrementally they are all data. You just
manage it through JavaScript. It is nothing
amazingly special, but it really improves
that whole user experience.
As you saw earlier on from the Lynx demo,
our whole DOM, our whole object model for
this application is -- it is semantically
defined. So it is consistent across all these
browsers.
The main thing that you will notice is when
we saw in the Lynx demo you navigate from
article to another article. That navigation
is just handled by a normal Lynx.
So what you do with a browser that supports
JavaScript and you want to keep them inside
this single-page app, again it is a very similar
thing. If you have ever used a JQuery, you
basically just hijack the browser click, do
some of your custom business logic, so in
this case a fetch article, and then just prevent
the default action from occurring.
I mean, we have been doing these things for
quite a while. It is just one of those nice
little things that we did inside our application
that really just makes this whole experience
kind of cohesive and inside that one page.
But the question that everyone asks when you
build these single-page apps is, well, single-page
apps break the Web because they don't allow
you to deep link. They very rarely keep the
state inside the URL. We kind of solved that
by playing -- expanding our use of the history
API. So it is kind of worth going through
the history -- a brief history of history,
I suppose, of how actual browsers have managed
navigation over the last couple of years.
In 2,000 when we were all building our Pearl
apps and everything, we had a URL structure
that normally closely mimicked the directory
and file -- the directory and file structure.
So you would have a category and inside that
category you might say, Well, this is a list
of technology articles and the server would
actually render that out and send it to the
client. As AJAX took off and we started building
applications which were pretty much inside
this single-page container, we still wanted
to have the ability to bookmark individual
pieces of state. So you would use the hash-tag
or -- the hash-tag, sorry, that's a Twitterrism.
You would use a document fragment syntax that's
there to kind of indicate some state and make
it bookmarkable.
But the problem obviously with using the document
fragment is that the server never sees this
data so your application can't be built by
the server in its entirety. You will load
it in the browser and then the browser will
go and fetch some data.
Again, not only because the server can't respond
with all the data upfront, the search engines
are having a whole lot of trouble actually
being able to actually parse the data in a
consistent manner. So some search engines
try to standardize on a common format for
using a document fragment syntax to indicate
a particular bit of state inside your browser.
But that wasn't great. But if you look at
the URLs that, say, modern Web developers
are using today, they look pretty much exactly
the same as they did in 2000. What is the
difference between now and then? Well, the
main difference is that use of the HTML5 history
API. It is a really simple API. It, basically,
allows you to change the URL of the browser
purely from the client's side.
As you can see from this code here, it is
a simple command called push state. Basically
you give the browser the URL you want it to
be on the screen, the title so it looks nice
when you bookmark it, and maybe some application-specific
states. We didn't need any particular JavaScript
objects inside our app pushed into the history
but you can do that.
And then as the user is navigating around
the application using forwards and backwards
buttons, there is an event that fires pop
state, which essentially you just hook into
here. And in our application, we just chose
to listen to the document location. You can
actually do whatever you want inside this
function. We just said, Well, we're going
to look at document location, parse it out
and then go and fetch the category data. So
if the URL match business, we would fetch
the business data.
But especially in user application, you never
know all of the URLs that your application
will encompass. You might know all the categories,
but you won't know every single article. So
managing your code like this isn't great.
So we made a framework called Leviroutes.
It is on Getup as well.
We made a framework called Leviroutes, which
is basically a URL routing framework. If you
have ever used App Engine or Ruby On Rails,
the syntax is relatively similar. It, basically,
allows to you define specific URL types inside
your JavaScript, inside your client and then
respond to them with your own kind of custom
business logic. So in our case if the article
looks like a category -- or the URL, sorry,
looks like a category, we go and fetch the
category data. And then if the article -- sorry,
I keep saying this. If the URL looks like
an article, we then go and fetch the article
data. It's actually pretty simple, but it
allows you to keep -- keep your application-specific
logic to a minimum and just make it very readable.
So we saw from the Lynx demo we were rendering
data from the server. All the application
data, in our case categories and articles
is being generated by the server. But also
at the same time, we had these really rich
interactive applications on, say, the smartphone
and tablet where all the data was located
into the client at one time. So that presents
a problem.
You need to have potentially two templates,
manage them in potentially different languages,
whether it is Python and Pearl and then on
the client side in JavaScript. How did you
go about doing it?
We used a basic technique called dual-side
templating, and we combine that with a framework
called Mustache which, basically, allows you
to maintain one common template across client
and server.
As long as your data format is consistent
throughout your entire application, you can
basically just render the same data. It substitutes
all the variable names, renders some nice
HTML and then you present that to the client.
Sorry.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Okay. So we are actually
talking about offline here. You already saw
some of the offline apps mentioned in the
keynote today, like "New York Times" reader
and "Sports Illustrated" was mentioned. So
this is possible now on the Web. There are
technologies that let us do it. And fortunately
enough for us, there are technologies that
allow us to do it in the phones and mobile
devices as well.
You've actually just seen these apps actually
work offline on the various devices.
The first of those technologies -- And there
is really two of them that work side by side.
The first is AppCache. And this is the ability
to actually store the entire application logic
on the device, just like you would install
an app from the Android market. It would be
sitting there on your device. It will be there
even when the user is not connected.
To use AppCache, it is really straightforward
actually. In the basic case, you just link
to the cache manifest file from your HTML
tag. And in the cache manifest, you simply
list all of the assets of your app. And those
-- that's the JavaScript, the CSS images and
so on.
The first time the user visits your app, the
browser will download all of the assets you've
listed in the manifest. And the next time
they visit it, it will immediately serve those
assets. It won't even check to the server
at all. It will actually work offline.
Every time you do visit, if you are online,
it will keep checking and it will download
in the background all the new assets whenever
that one file changes. So if you are connected,
all that ever happens is just a single request
to see if the cache manifest has changed.
And if you are offline, the application keeps
working as normal.
The other side of this is storing actually
data which might be, for instance, an email
the user is composing. In this case, it is
actually articles you've read. We've kept
it pretty simple here. We've used LocalStorage,
which is a very basic, easy-to-use API. It
gives you, basically, just a JavaScript object.
LocalStorage, you can use it. You can treat
it as just a JavaScript object where you can
say, localstorage.food equals bar and later
on you retrieve it with localstorage.food.
And that's an object that only your domain
can see. No other Web apps can get hold of
that, read it and write it, and it's a very
simple interface. That's why there are also
these other ones that have actually got more
complexity to them. They give you the benefits
of speed and so on, but not quite as simple.
So we've got that with Web SQL database. It's
basically an entire SQL database sitting in
the browser. You can imagine that's going
to be quite complex. It does have great performance
characteristics in terms of being able to
search for a lot of data or being able to
just do things asynchronously, which is the
way a lot of the Web apps work.
But that's actually being deprecated, so it
is actually quite widely supported as well
in the current -- because it's in Webkit,
it's actually in the two apps that you've
actually -- or the two devices you've already
seen here, but at the same time it is being
deprecated. It's never made it to mainstream
use across all of the desktop browsers.
So what now seems to be the way of the future
is indexed database. It's already there in
Chrome and in FireFox on the desktop and hopefully
it will make its way to the mobile browsers
soon, and it kind of gives you the best of
both worlds. A lot of simplicity you get from
local storage, but the speed and performance
characteristics of Web SQL.
>>Paul Kinlan: So we said for each of these
devices they have a marketplace, a store built
in, for users to go and find applications.
Luckily, the web is no different. But let's
just kind of jump back to our idea of having
a consistent common URL structure.
It's really important. We can't stress it
enough. If you combine a consistent URL structure
across your app on the client side and the
server side using the HTML history and potentially
the dual side templating, it's really easy
for search engines to go and aggregate your
content. If it's entirely client side application,
it's really hard for search engines to be
able to go and do the job that they do best
and deliver users to your application.
But it's not always about just search engines.
You know, each of these devices do have native
marketplaces on.
You can use services such as Phonegap, for
instance, to actually just package your application
-- package your application up into, you know
-- using an existing Web application, you
can use it, package it up, and then deliver
it into these native marketplaces.
But again, it's not just about native devices.
There are a lot of different web stores.
If you're building a desktop application -- I
think Seth was talking about it yesterday,
or there was a talk about it yesterday about
the Web Store. Chrome Web Store is a great
place for you to go and get your applications
discovered. But from the mobile context, there
are a lot of third-party, you know, web stores
available. It's just relatively easily to
get into them as well.
So we have a whole range, a whole spectrum
of different ways to get your application
discovered from traditional search engines.
The power of the web is that these search
engines can index your data, but then you
can also go a little bit more native.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Touch. We want to get
our apps working with touch the same way the
native apps do, and it's amazing when you
think about these gestures, things like swiping
and pinch-to-zoom.
When you use a device these days, they feel
so natural but they've only been around for
a couple of years, so it's -- it is something
that actually just works with the way we think
as humans, and I think we want to be able
to cooperate with that thinking and actually
implement that in our apps.
Fortunately, we have this, again, with HTML5,
and you've seen it in the IO Reader layers,
the ones that are actually specifically related
to touch devices.
We have this with touch events. So we don't
have to work around this like the earlier
browsers were doing with your old-school mouse
events. You've actually got built-in touch
support with events like touchstart and touchend.
As far as those gestures, those things like
swiping and fling and pinch zoom, those are
starting to come into the standard. They're
not all there yet. So what we did in in this
app is we created a little library to help
with it that would actually detect when the
user's done a significant swipe action, significant
enough to actually register and respond to
it.
So this is actually a little library where
you attach it to an object, also jQuery based,
and it actually will fire when the user's
actually done that swipe action in one direction
and let go, whether it's horizontal or vertical.
It also fires as the user is moving, moving
their fingers back and forth, so that you
actually saw the stories being swiped back
and forth on the phone, or up and down, so
we actually can respond to that as the user
is doing it, which is a much better way to
design user interfaces than five seconds later.
And we can also do click, which is what happens
when the user opens the article, and long
hold. We need to implement those things, because
if we're capturing all the touch events, they
won't always fire, the actual built-in click
event won't always fire, so we need the library
to do the whole thing.
We actually found it really convenient to
develop a lot of this app on the desktop,
even in the case of the phone API -- or the
phone form factor, because the desktop is
where you're actually coding, so it's really
easy to be able to switch windows and see
how the app is working. And it's also where
you can actually take advantage of tools like
the Chrome dev tools to actually do your debugging.
So to that end, we actually built into this
library a few switches to make sure that it
will work nicely with mouse events as well,
if there is no touch support there.
And also, just a tip about debugging is you
can actually debug on the device. We were
doing that in the later stages of this project
and with Android it's actually really easy.
There's an URL up there where I've just put
a few steps in. Just to attach your device
by USB or you can do the same thing on the
emulator and you just have to run a couple
of commands and in a couple of minutes you've
actually got console logging there. You can
log your own messages and you can also see
error messages coming from the browsing environment.
Just a final note and a bit of a caveat on
this whole area of touch interfaces.
It's really easy to fall into the so-called
uncanny valley. It's a term from robotics
that means you've got kind of close to there,
but eerily slightly not there and something's
just a little bit off.
So the recommendation here is: Try to stay
right away from that. If you don't think you're
going to get very close, you know, just make
something that's very different. There are
many successful apps you can see on the various
mobile marketplaces which are a very idiosyncratic
interface. You see a lot of games that devise
their own mechanisms for menus and so on.
It is actually possible to do that. You don't
have to emulate the native look and feel.
But -- so if you're going to do that, you
know, stay clear away from it. If you're going
to do what we've tried to do here, we recommend,
you know, trying to take the time to make
it as close as possible so you don't end up
in that weird middle ground.
>>Paul Kinlan: So we mentioned early on about
the form factor detection and how the differing
like interaction styles that you have for
the different types of devices is really important.
However, in each of those classes of devices,
there are a whole multitude of -- you know,
of different screen sizes and, you know, different
capabilities, and how do you actually build
your applications to cater to that.
It's actually quite simple in the end.
The first thing that we did in our application
was we defined a viewport. The viewport is
basically there to stop the existing web from
completely breaking in mobile devices. So
it defines this kind of -- well, it basically
tends to be like say a 1024-by-768 browser
so that the pages can render correctly, and
then it will scale the page down to fit the
screen or allow you to zoom in and zoom out,
so that you can pan around it, and not actually
have to have the web developer of the existing
site, you know, cater especially to your device.
But when we're building these applications,
we don't want that functionality, so it's
-- it's relatively easy. We're basically saying
this virtual viewport has to be the exact
same size as the device width. And that basically
allows you to get sometimes a near one-to-one
correspondence between physical device screen
size and, you know, what's reported to your
application.
But you still have the ability to enable zoom
and zoom-out and all the kind of traditional-based
pinch-based gestures inside your application.
We chose not to do it in our application.
We said, you know, we're like specifically
targeting smartphones. We're going to have
to design our application to work well across
all these devices. We don't need to have zoom
in and zoom out and the traditional, you know,
pinch gesture, so we've disabled it.
But it's -- how do I say this? It's entirely
up to you. If you have an application which
is suited to zoom in/zoom out and the native
-- you know, those native abilities, keep
them in. We chose not to do it in our app.
And the next is media queries.
With form factor detection, we're definitely
not trying to get rid of the idea of media
queries. We're just trying to make it more
manageable for us to build applications that
are responsive to the different screen sizes.
It's a lot easier to build an application
that will respond to different smartphone
screen sizes or different tablet screen sizes
than have to have one style that responds
to all of them at the same time.
And media queries are just a great way to
build applications that are at least aware
of the type of screen, the size screen, that
they're on, and in our case, when we showed
the demo of the smartphone, we had two different
orientations, a portrait and a landscape.
You can just target different CSS to say the
landscape mode. Maybe hide some images because
you value vertical space. And then in the
portrait mode, you just go and show all the
images because you've got a lot of vertical
space and there's a lot more freedom in that
mode.
So we're actually getting quite close to the
end.
It's -- so we're just kind of going -- all
those images are gone. Cool.
[Laughter]
So they're supposed to be nice text. We've
solved them. So we think we've done an okay
job at solving, you know, these six different
interaction styles -- or six different problems
of -- you know, that we face as mobile web
developers.
The different interaction styles are managed
through form factor detection, so you can
target specific user interaction styles to
the different types of devices.
We've shown you how, you know, single-page
apps, traditional AJAX methods, can really
help improve your application just by incrementally
loading the data and not having this jarring
experience when you're navigating from one
page to the next. And then with --
>>Michael Mahemoff: Are we going to do a relay
--
>>Paul Kinlan: Yeah. No. Then using appcache,
not only can you make new application load,
you know, instantly, you can just make it
work offline as well, and then if you combine
that with local storage, you can at least
keep the data, you know, in memory and in
browser, so that the user doesn't have that
experience of being completely offline.
We can make our applications discoverable.
Things like the server side templating and
the client side -- the dual side templating
technique we talked about allow you to render
and present data to search engines really
efficiently, get that -- and get discovered.
And then you can obviously use the native
frameworks as well to actually package your
Web application.
We've shown you who you can build applications
that are responsive not just to basic touch
commands but the gestures as well. There's
a nice little library Mike wrote. And then
just using the viewport and media queries,
we can actually build applications that are
responsive to the different screen sizes.
>>Michael Mahemoff: So the idea here has not
been just about targeting the mobile devices,
but about using this technology of HTML5 to
reach all of the different types of devices
you might care for, to expose your services
to, to users, and to that end we've also got
these other types of apps as well.
So we've got a desktop app. So this is not
the desktop app. That's the TV app here, so
I'll show you the TV first.
So this is actually where we've got the TV
where it's that experience where you're 10
foot back, you want to just get a bit of an
overview about what the stories are. You can
see them easily.
And taking -- taking into account the user
interface on the input side and the output
side.
So on the input side, I'm able to control
all of this. I can use a pointing device if
I want, a mouse, but I'm able to control all
of it just with the keyboard with just the
arrow keys, you know, which you would have
on a very basic remote control. So that's
the input side only.
Output side, you can see how it gives you
that very big overview.
And in the case of the desktop app -- ooooh.
Have we got a problem? Okay. I'll leave it
to the screen shot. You can see that later.
Some problems. Sometimes with the offlining,
it can be a problem where if it's a slow connection,
which seems to be the case here, I think,
you can actually get something going, so -- oh,
yeah, we can switch over to here.
So sometimes you'll get a situation where
it downloads some of it but not all of it,
which we haven't optimized for, but you can
see it here.
So you get -- again, you get the ability to
use keyboard shortcuts which kind of fits
in with the natural style that people assume
should be there on the desktop, as well as
the mouse.
So again, it's that input style of keyboard
shortcuts and mouse, and the output style
just taking advantage of all the features
of a standard desktop browser.
Let's jump back.
And the point about this has been that we're
able to develop this all quite independently
from one another, so we actually -- Paul did
most of the work on the architecture and the
core logic of the app and each of us wrote
the separate layers. Two of us were in London,
two of us were over here in Mountain View,
and we didn't have to do that much communication
between each other, because it was just a
standard contract for how we'd actually write
these apps.
So you can see here, you know, the vast majority
of the logic in IO Reader is able to be reused.
And I think that's about it.
So you can see the code's going online. The
actual -- the actual news source that you
see, it's coming from the guardian API. It's
probably going to be one too many hits for
their API if we leave that running, so it's
really something where you can actually plug
in your own data source and you could actually
do, you know, something for your own apps
or for any other kind of services that are
on the web. That's a separate module that's
part of IO Reader on the server side. It's
a node component that you can actually write
your own to get different sort of data. And
there are various open source libraries as
well that we've used in here that you'll be
able to see. When the slides come online,
you'll have those links.
But for right now, we've got a link to Moderator.
I don't know, has anyone -- what we did. There's
another one that doesn't work online. Maybe
we should switch to the link on there.
>>Paul Kinlan: Should we give it a go?
>>Michael Mahemoff: Yeah. We're just going
to jump to the link that we've got in the
slides.
But meanwhile, we do have time for questions
and we're interested to know like if you've
got any challenges you've come across or any
other tips. We'd like to hear about them.
So please, if you've got questions, come up.
Otherwise, we'll look at Moderator as well
in a moment, once we're back online.
>> Hi.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Hi.
>> Can you talk about the interaction between
the manifest file and which files are downloaded
compared to the script tags and the style
tags that are in the head compared to the
-- that slide you showed with Modernizer which
actually selects which styles --
>>Paul Kinlan: Yeah. So we actually -- we
didn't have an amazing amount of scripts inside
our application, so each individual form factor
is actually embedded in the one sheet.
So if you look at the code, it's maybe two
lines -- two bits of JavaScript for smartphone,
two files for desktop, and we just downloaded
all of them because it's relatively low latency
at the moment. This actually allows you to
quickly flip in between the form factors and
not have to re-download any new assets and
then validate your appcache.
>> And so does the manifest file -- all of
those files get downloaded and they're all
referenced in the head as well?
>>Paul Kinlan: Yeah, they're referenced -- well,
there are some core assets that are referenced
from the head. The common controller is in
the head, and then each of the -- the -- like
the phone JavaScript and the iPad -- or the
tablet JavaScript, at least, is referenced
in the form factor loader.
Because it's on the server side, we have control
over, you know, what's gets rendered where,
so we know all the files that are needed for
the whole entire application, so they are
always available at the moment.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Take one from Moderator.
>>Paul Kinlan: Yeah. Should we just do one
from Moderator? Just pick the first one. JQuery,
mobile, SproutCore mobile, Sencha Touch, what's
being used? In our application, we didn't
use anything specific. It was just all normal
JavaScript.
Did you want to explain the differences?
>>Michael Mahemoff: Briefly, the differences
between these three frameworks, I guess get
JQuery mobile, it is a very new framework.
It has got a very permissive license. And
it is very much like JQuery, very much a microkernel
with some very basic sort of widgets at the
moment and the ability to do theming as well.
But it is very much a standard sort of open
source project like JQuery.
The other two are more commercially backed.
In fact, both of those, SproutCore and Sencha,
are here at I/O and Sandbox is, if you want
to talk to them.
SproutCore is aiming to be an app where you
can sort of write just HTML, focus on something
that might even be desktop-related or actually
take advantage of some of their widgets and
then they are aiming to offer services on
top of that. So I think it is a little bit
of a less commercial license because it is
not jewel license like Sencha Touch. It also
has got the MIT license like JQuery. So you
can use it however you want.
And then they are planning to sort of add
extra services to it like being able to package
things up and distribute to stores and do
caching and so on. Sencha Touch is starting
to become a very big commercial operation.
You can still use it as a GPL3 license. They
have got some very sophisticated widgets available.
So as always, horses to courses and check
them all out.
>>> My question is in regards to the offline
of a Web app. If I had an app where a user
could post, let's say, information through
the Web app and they were offline, is there
a method or a technology that then the device
or the app would recognize they are online
and push that back to my site or the app?
>>Paul Kinlan: So that means each of the devices
normal has an event, I think -- online is
an event on the document so you can at least
tell when you're on. It doesn't work across
all devices because it depends on whether
the network interface is up.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Actually, that originally
wasn't supported on Chrome because they had
the intuition that you should actually just
be trying to push it online. And if it doesn't
work, you handle the exception.
>>Paul Kinlan: One thing we do do in our application
at least is we don't necessarily post any
data, but we intercept every request as best
we can for fetching the data so we can then
cache it. I think the same thing applies when
you are trying to post data. You can basically
get the on-error states on XML HTTP request
and then respond to it that way and then just
make sure the data is cached.
>>Michael Mahemoff: It makes a good point
because we need more libraries to do this
sort of thing. We are starting to get some
libraries like Lawn Chair and PersistJS that
will eventually have different layers probably
to sort of fall back depending on what mechanism
is there for LocalStorage.
What we need is actually higher-level libraries
that will do things like caching and syncing.
They are not really there yet in JavaScript.
>>> Thank you.
>>> This isn't a question. It is just a comment
about console.log. Console.log on Android
is not universal to every single Android device.
For example, the HTC -- mostly HTC lines,
not the dex one but the commercially available
HTC lines do not have console.log. That's
why it is a good idea to actually develop
your mobile application in the emulator instead
of the device in this one case.
>>Paul Kinlan: It is actually interesting.
You can do About call on some of the Android
devices, and you can get -- if it supports
console, you can actually get a console log
inside the application on the device as well.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Right now you type about.debug
and use it to toggle or not.
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Michael Mahemoff: Let's take one from the
Moderator. Next one: Is what's your take on
app versus mobile Web sites?
>>Paul Kinlan: Depends on the content, I think.
>>Michael Mahemoff: It does, yeah.
>>Paul Kinlan: If it is content-based, it
is a site. If it is functionality, then it
is more app-like.
>>Michael Mahemoff: I think we are seeing
the same thing. Paul and I have worked a lot
on the Chrome Web store. I think it is also
about being aware of the fact that apps do
have special privileges. They can do things
like inapp payments easily and maybe they've
got other ability to get involved with the
hardware and so on. They can also communicate
back and forth.
There are techniques that you can use on the
various platforms like the kinds of things
Phone Gap does that let you communicate with
native capabilities. So if you actually do
need to tune into those native capabilities.
You can do that with apps as well. I think
there is always a role for Web sites.
And actually with phones, you got the ability
to send a SMS with a link in it so it is really
convenient for people to just click on a link
from an SMS as well as they might see it in
Twitter or something. All those things don't
open in apps. They open in phones, so you
still need at least some mobile Web presence.
>>> I have a couple of questions. What's the
best way -- Normally you detect a difference
between the phone and desktop. Like, usually
you use the user agent. So is that the best
way or you go -- what is the best way to handle
it?
>>Paul Kinlan: Yes, that's actually a very
good question. So how do you actually detect
the differences between the devices? We've
actually used a combination of user agent
string check-in in the JavaScript side of
things. But then specific media queries as
well.
So the formfactorjs can take a whole lot of
different expressions that will determine
whether it is a particular device class or
not.
>>Michael Mahemoff: In the case of formfactorjs,
we have left that kind of modular so it is
actually down to a community that doesn't
yet exist. That would be the concept, you
would be able to have a whole grassroots collection.
>>Paul Kinlan: Yeah. We have media queries
like TV and pretty much only TV support the
media TV query. So you can basically use that
media query to say we definitely think you
are on TV and then download these assets.
It is a combination.
>>Michael Mahemoff: It is always a messy approach.
It is not very clean cut. That's why we also
provide the ability to jump back to the standard
desktop app, and it's something that's a bit
controversial doing this sort of thing.
We feel like the standard approaches that
people talk about in terms of feature detection
and responsive Web design, they are just not
enough to have quite distinct user interfaces
for these different form factors. Even if
it is messy, we would rather have some sort
of guess about the form factor.
>>> Okay. And another question was, like,
normally in applications, if you have sort
of an event where you click it, like it is
a map coordinate, you click it and it will
launch a map UI. So say, for example, if I
were to develop something for picture, if
someone clicks and holds on the picture, if
I want to raise to set as a a wallpaper or
something like that, is there a way possible
right now?
>>Paul Kinlan: That's kind of more Android
specific. I'm under the impression that the
applications respond to when those intents
broadcast from inside within your Web application.
The other way around, I don't think you can
-- I don't think -- it won't launch the browser
naturally unless the browser is actually listening
to that intent.
>>> Maybe I didn't clarify. If I have a Web
application and I'm browsing, like, pictures,
from that, is there a way, like, to have new
intents as to -- if some application is registered
for, say, if you click on it, in the browser
itself and then you want to set it as -- you
want to crop that wallpaper or set that as
a wallpaper, can you do that?
>>Michael Mahemoff: Not that I know of. You
just have the ability what we show, which
is the share feature. That's as far as I know.
There are standards so there are standard
protocols for doing things like launching
the phone, if you want to show a phone number,
you can do a tel prefix and so on but not
in a general sense as far as I know.
>>> Thank you.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Thank you. Maybe time
for one more question.
>>Paul Kinlan: Should we do one more question
from here.
>>Michael Mahemoff: And then we'll wrap up.
>>Paul Kinlan: A good example out there of
a real-life HTML5 implementation that runs
on desktop, phone and tablet with offline
capability? Gmail seems like a poster child
more than any others.
So Gmail doesn't. IO Reader? That's a great
--
>>Michael Mahemoff: Yeah. I think the "real
life" was intended there for a reason.
>>Paul Kinlan: Yeah. Exactly. So this is one
of the things that we're trying to do. We're
trying to reach developers and help them build
applications this way because I don't think
that many people are building those types
of apps at the moment.
>>Michael Mahemoff: I'll give you a couple
of examples. One interesting one to look at
is bit.ly, bit.ly's own app. It works nicely
on the mobiles. It does canvas graphics to
actually generate charts, which is basically
the same thing it does on the desktop, and
it seems to be quite natural on both of those.
And also look at Netflix. There's a long article
on Function Source Log recently about how
Netflix is targeting over 400 different types
of devices with HTML5. It's not really the
same app but it is actually the fact that
they are using the same technology stack,
again and again, based on HTML5 and actually
they're specifically aiming it keep it within
Webkit.
>>Paul Kinlan: Actually, can I answer one
about the pushstate? We've got a question
about is the window.pushstate history manipulation
supported on all major platforms or is it
just a feature for future applications?
It's not supported on every single platform
at the moment. Webkit has got a really good
coverage of pushstate. The reason why we created
a wrapper library is because we can't always
rely on the fact -- or this routes framework,
we can't always rely on the fact that pushstate
is supported.
So the application -- if you use Lynx, you'd
see it use the document fragment to indicate
active articles and things like that, so the
whole routing framework can take advantage
of on-hash change or just normal on-load events
as well to actually detect the current state
of the application. So we haven't got full
coverage. I think more browsers are going
to support it because this -- I mean, literally
it's the fact that you can have a single consistent
URL structure on the server side. On the client
side, it just makes it so powerful.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Okay. So let's take one
final question from the audience here and
then we'll wrap up.
>> Thanks. How are you using Mustache? Were
you actually sending different markup to each
client and like transporting JSON or was it
all CSS based?
>>Paul KinlanActually, we've got the same
consistent HTML DOM structure throughout the
whole of the application and across all the
different types of devices.
Moustache was just there to -- when we get
data back from the article. So we will go
and make a request to the guardian API, and
it's in its own format, and we -- we've like
munched that into a consistent object model
for our side.
If it's an AJAX request, it's JSON to the
client and then rendered using that same template
that is held on the server side, and the server
is -- again, because it's all node and it's
a JSON object, we just basically render the
same thing.
>>Michael Mahemoff: But the reason we use
Mustache -- because it's all node, we could
have used anything, right? Because it's actually
Javascript on either side.
We just used Mustache really as a proof of
concept. We wanted to show that even if we
did our server in Python or whatever, we'd
still be able to use that same pattern of
taking the same data structure, but on the
server the data structure is like a raw data
structure. It's not really represented as
a string of JSON. It's just a data structure
that gets pushed into the Mustache library.
Whereas on the browser, it is actually JSON
that gets pulled down by XHR and processed
on demand as the user actually requests that
content.
Yeah. I think we're done. Okay.
>>Paul Kinlan: Thank you.
>>Michael Mahemoff: Thank you.
%%%Chuck3end